bonjour leslie pedro sanchez qui
voudraient gracier les responsables
indépendantistes catalans ils sont
actuellement incarcérés ils ont été
condamnés en 2017 pour tentative de
sécession à leslie c'est la première
fois que le gouvernement espagnol ouvre
la porte sur ce sujet tout à fait il ya
un temps pour la punition et un temps
pour l'entendre c'est avec ces mots que
pedro sanchez a émis la possibilité
d'une grâce des leaders indépendantistes
au parlement ils purgent actuellement
des peines de prison qui varie entre 9
et 13 ans de prison alors on le rappelle
ils sont douze à avoir été condamnée
principalement pour sédition pour leur
rôle dans l'organisation d'un référendum
un dea en octobre 2010 est un référendum
indépendantiste puisse était suivie une
déclaration unilatérale d'indépendance
alors sa responsable politique la
plupart sont actuellement en activité
politique depuis leur cellule et pour
pedro sanchez les relations ne pourront
pas revenir à la normale tant qu'il y
aura des responsables politiques
derrière les barreaux alors il devra
utiliser le système de grâce royale pour
effacer la condamnation et le roi
pourrait donc signer la mesure alors
bien entendu les réactions ne se sont
pas fait attendre et la proposition
divise même au centre du parti
socialiste est dans les faits leslie est
ce qu'il est possible que la grèce soit
appliquée alors ça ne sera pas si simple
puisque la cour suprême avait condamné
les dirigeants indépendantistes en
octobre 2019 et elle se dit opposée à
toute grâce partielle ou totale dans un
rapport officiel
les juges ont notamment mis en avant
l'absence de repentance des dirigeants
indépendantistes
et puis il faut préciser que les députés
indépendantistes sont partis de la
majorité parlementaire qui soutient le
gouvernement espagnol et donc les
magistrates s'appuie sur la piste
titution en expliquant qu'un
gouvernement ne peut pas s'auto gracié
ce qui rendrait la grâce invalides
alors du côté des indépendantistes eux
ils préféreraient une loi d'aministie le
nouveau président de la catalogne a
déclaré notre proposition et l'amnestie
mais nous ne nous opposerons à aucune
mesure qui pourrait soulager la douleur
des prisonniers et puis de son côté il y
a car l'espèce des mains nues qui est
contre la grâce puisqu'il aime dire à
l'international que l'espagne n'est pas
une démocratie alors en tout cas mais
d'euros sanchez
joue un gros risque il devra présenter
la mesure avec pédagogie dans les
prochaines semaines merci beaucoup
leslie pour toutes ces explications
leslie singla en direct de barcelone
ce matin